haverá quem diga que felicidade é você
ter o que você quer
eis aí a primeira dificuldade não é
possível porque quando você quer é
porque você não tem ainda
quando você tem aí você já não quer mais
o desejo é sempre por aquilo que falta
por aquilo que nos faz falta ea energia
mobilizada para ir atrás daquilo que
queremos sempre encontra na falta a sua
grande motivação mas aí é claro um dia
como nem tudo é tão cruel e tão difícil
você consegue o que você tanto queria e
quando você consegue você não deseja
mais você não ama mais os brinquedos
recebidos no natal estão num baú de
desejos assassinados pela presença
mortos pelo consumo e as crianças querem
os outros que elas ainda não têm
a sociedade não pode nos deixar a
desejar de qualquer jeito
essa força que temos para ir atrás
daquilo que nos faz falta ela não pode
se manifestar no caos é preciso cada
sociedade sabe disso organizar o desejo
direcionar a energia para aquilo que não
vai causar problema para troféus
legítimos pra conquistas que são
ordenadoras da vida na sociedade
na escola a gente aprende a desejar
aquilo que faz falta
eu me lembro no primário era um dos
quatro primeiros anos do ensino
fundamental a tia maria das graças dizia
assim o primário é a preparação para o
ginásio ea então a gente ficou quatro
anos esperando o ginásio o ginásio seria
bacana ela prometeu no ginásio seria
mais legal no ginásio a gente teria mais
liberdade ea então quando chegou o
ginásio tínhamos todos os motivos para
acreditar que tudo seria lindo
em agosto o prazer haveria felicidade
mas mudou a coordenadora entrou a tia
maria das graças e disse olha os quatro
anos do ginásio são para preparar para o
colegial no colegial sim é outro prédio
é bem mais legal não tem que usar um
uniforme você pode escolher entre exatas
humanas e biológicas você já vai ser
adulto vai ser livre e portanto vai ser
feliz era um só mais quatro anos
esperando aí chegou o colegial nos
primeiros dias fomos pra escola
acreditando que a felicidade de chegada
ea cdu idéias e linda haveria
prazer boas e felicidade mas agora 101
coordenador enorme um cara gigante
chamado mario zan e disse o colegial
vamos deixar de frescura é preparar para
o vestibular
ficamos mais três anos já são 11
desejando e e aí todo mundo nos dizendo
quando quando aconteceu isso quando
aconteceu aquilo quando for lá a ver a
felicidade
chegamos na faculdade os primeiros dias
pareciam cumpriu a promessa
nossa tinha semana do calouro michetti
havia bebida havia muito sexo é muito
legal havia felicidade mas depois de
três dias a gente começou a passear
pelos corredores estágio em estágio em
estágio acolá e os veteranos dizendo
malandros e não penal está fudido você
não pegar estágio não vai dar certo e
nunca mais vai pegar o bonde da história
o trabalho vai escapar se vai morrer nas
sarjetas e nunca mais vai trabalhar e
você vai atrás do estágio com sangue no
olho faca nos dentes até que você
consegue um estágio você volta pra casa
eufórico a felicidade chegou eu tenho um
estágio e no primeiro dia do estágio que
tratam de estagiário e aí você vê que
não é muito legal o que disseram pra
você na verdade tem até uma boa de
estagiário um super presidente de uma
empresa reúne seus vice-presidentes e
pergunta faz uma charada um enigma ele
disse escuta aqui o que eu faço é prazer
ou é trabalho 24 horas para responder
nossas bpp reúnem seus diretores reúnem
seus capatazes reúnem seus asseclas
risco
o que o chef faz aqui é prazer ou
trabalho aí os pp reúne os diretores se
reúnem e aquilo vem descendo as empresas
a empresa toda a hierarquia da empresa
até que não sendo o corredor tem o
estagiário
ele tem filhas de trabalho ele tem dois
telefones na orelha ele tem um monte de
coisa vai fazer alguém chega para ele e
diz em você eu tenho que responder o que
o presidente faz aqui é prazer ou é
trabalho e ele diz é lógico que a
brasileira fosse trabalha eu fazia
lógico
aí você consegue um estágio e alguém já
te disse você não for efetivado não terá
valido de nada o estágio e como você é
bem bacana bem aguerrido tem um dia que
você tenha carteira assinada
você tem o diploma da universidade você
chega em casa e diz foram 16 anos se
preparando
você é o orador da turma na formatura
eles são 16 anos aqui mas a felicidade
agora chegou eu tenho um emprego e eu
tenho pasme com diploma universitário
no primeiro dia do trabalho você é
recebido por um chefe o chefe olha pra
você e diz a empresa tem 15 níveis
você está no g 15 g15 vale menos que um
estagiário não tem nenhum lugar para pôr
sua bicicleta no estacionamento
você não vale nada aí você disse para
subir como é que eu faço aí ele disse
tem que perseguir metas bater meta e
fazer resultado aí você olha e diz que o
que é exatamente neta ele diz é o
seguinte são como cenouras que vão
rápido você sai correndo pé da cenoura
entrega a cenoura pra mim eu te dou
outra cenoura você pegar e você assim
vai batendo meta e vai subindo g14 do
g13 é bem legal
aí você pega senhor entrega cenoura pega
a cenoura entrada cenoura mega sena o
internacional pega será entregue a
cenoura você tá subindo oito anos depois
se encontra o mesmo chefe na cafeteria
da empresa diz malandro eu tenho uma
única curiosidade onde a essência tanto
a cenoura
funciona você vai subindo subindo
subindo de repente você começa a ser
chamado com letras letras inglês e tudo
o que é inglês vale muito
o cse fosse ou se cocoa e colocou se
filiou e aí você começa a perceber que
nossa mas sempre tem alguém acima
sempre tem alguém humilhando você sempre
tem alguém olhando de cima para baixo e
aí um dia te fazem uma festa ou saber no
estádio allianz parque
o dia que fizerem uma festa pra você
você já dançou vão te dar uma plaquinha
dizendo obrigado perseguidor de cenoura
mas você agora envelhecido será
substituído por alguém mais jovem e mais
iludido
alguém ainda dirá quando você se
aposentar vai ser bem legal
você pega o dinheiro que sobrou você tem
uma chacrinha tem até um lago e você
pesca aos 80 anos está nas últimas com a
família chorando em volta e ainda vai
chegar alguém pode acreditar vai chegar
alguém para dizer nada de tristeza
nada de tristeza porque o melhor ainda
está por vir
você fragilizado e sem forças o serviço
malandro me enganaram por 80 anos e você
não percebeu que talvez minha vida tinha
alguma chance de ser feliz não é quando
nada acontecer mas é já aqui nesse canto
do estádio ou a felicidade está aqui ou
não estará em nenhum outro lugar porque
a vida está aqui e aí é claro aí você
pensa que eu poderia ter esperado a
minha hora de entrar
eu poderia estar ali sentadinho eu
poderia pensar assim
nossa mais uma palestra depois que me
aposentei na universidade esse é o meu
ganha pão todo dia tem uma felizmente a
família agradece então deixa ele lá
passar a régua livrar a cara
depois do almoço tem mais e aí a
felicidade seria quando isso aqui acabar
se eu fosse embora para poder descansar
para poder comer aí você diz pô mas que
pensamento tosco que pensamento pobre
que pensamento infeliz e cid ficar ali
esperando pra palestra acabar pra eu
poderá então ser feliz que coisa mais
medíocre
pois é mas você chama de rap a hora que
horas você chama de rap ao ar segunda às
8 da manhã às sextas 18 pra você repita
a hora que o trabalho acaba porque não
tenho direito
estou aqui trabalhando na hora que a
palestra acabar é que vai ser legal por
enquanto é um pedágio que eu tenho que
pagar pra felicidade quando tudo acabar
é você pensa tem alguma coisa errada
nessa história
lógico que tem eu podia estar ali
sentado
eu podia estar pensando assim eu nunca
tive aqui palestra nesse lugar nunca
mais nunca mais nem que a gente voltar
todo mundo seremos diferentes a cada
instante da vida é uma oportunidade
mágica e recuperável e virginal
absolutamente inédita e nunca antes
vivida é esse momento que eu tenho pra
fazer nesse lugar
o melhor que eu puder fazer eu tenho a
chance de fazer aqui melhor do que ontem
e melhor do que os 30 anos de
professorado que foram a minha vida
porque porque hoje eu sou melhor do que
ontem porque hoje eu sou mais competente
que ontem hoje eu sou mais preparado
mais experiente que ontem eu tenho a
chance de fazer o melhor da vida e ali
eu estava sentada dinho focado para
fazer aqui o melhor da vida a palestra
da vida o que melhor eu já fiz para que
possa ter graça não na hora que terminar
mas durant e quando a felicidade começa
antes é melhor para a vida
se esperar a sexta às 18 horas pra vida
ser feliz desculpa a tua vida é muito
ruim é bem melhor quando ela começa
antes se ela terá colorido cada vez que
você usar o instant vivido pra buscar
fazer o mais perfeito
a busca da excelência o pleno
desabrochar da própria essência a busca
da própria perfeição que não vai
acontecer no final de semana mas vai
acontecer já porque agora que a vida
acontece e eu tenho a chance mágica de
usar as melhores palavras os melhores
exemplos tocar você no seu espírito o a
máxima contundência e aí sim eu estarei
fazendo da minha vida uma vida de
desafios colorida e feliz não é quando
acabar é já de lamentarem demais o
momento e acaba porque se você me
perguntar e aqui não é mais ninguém
famoso aqui sou eu
felicidade é um pequeno segundo da vida
um pequeno instante em que você gostaria
de repetir
felicidade é aquele segundinho que você
não gostaria que a base mas como vai ter
que acabar
você usa inteligência para repetir pode
acontecer em qualquer lugar pode
acontecer no cinema você vai ver o daria
um segredo dos seus olhos e você pensa
nossa eu acho que eu vou voltar aqui com
a minha mãe para assistir a esse filme
isso é sintoma de felicidade no cinema
você está no bar o aspicuelta com alguém
que você não conhece e se alguém tem que
embora e se dispor deixa o telefone que
eu vou ligar pra gente marcar de novo e
sua felicidade no bar e tem até aquele
aluno aquele aluno que no último dia de
aula do curso vira pra você e diz o
professor
será que no ano que vem eu não poderia
assistir suas aulas de novo como 20
e aí você olha
uno e você vê que só uma razão para ele
querer fazer o mesmo curso outra vez ele
vai ter que admitir é que durante as
aulas
ele foi feliz e tomara tomara tenha sido
assim aqui tomara você não tenha nem
sentindo a minha chegada
tomara você tenha se deixado conduzir
pela minha fala pensado na própria vida
e lamentado que chegou a hora de eu me
pedir
tomara você pense que talvez se tivesse
trazido a mãe se tivesse sido meu aluno
se tivesse me olhado na internet
se tivesse me procurado antes talvez
tivesse antecipado esse encontro e se
alguma dessas coisas aconteceu admita
neste segundo aqui não depois
agora você foi feliz quando a vida
poderia ter durado um pouco mais quando
a poderia vida poderia se repetir um dia
tomara que tenha sido assim e aí é claro
se foi assim a meta que eu vim buscar
bater foi batida e foi alcançada porque
não há nada mais legal do que você num
lugar como esse proporcionar alguém que
você nunca viu um mísero segundo que
esse alguém gostaria de repetir com você
e se todos nós para além das nossas
metas cotidianas nos déssemos o trabalho
de proporcionar alguém do lado o
instante de vida que se alguém gostaria
um dia de repetir a nossa estaríamos
juntos costurando uma sociedade
infinitamente mais solidária uma
sociedade infinitamente mais justa mais
coesa mais harmoniosa e mais feliz
porque no final das contas isso aqui que
nós chamamos de brasil somos mas esse
temos que melhorar somos nós a melhorar
e se há algo a progredir somos nós a
fazer acontecer
somos todos corresponsáveis é hora de
juntos virarmos a página e patrocinarmos
com a nossa conduta ea nossa
inteligência uma convivência
e ora e mais justa que não seja para nós
mas que seja para aqueles que tanto
amamos e que não pediram para nascer e
que esperam encontrar quando começarem a
viver em um lugar bacana de convivência
porque viver bem é conviver bem viver
bem é viver bem com os outros viver bem
encontra a justiça para si para os
outros e isso é tarefa nossa não haverá
super heróis não haverá soluções
milagrosas não haverá grandes gênios não
só nos salvar
essa tarefa é exclusivamente nossa de
buscar uma felicidade através de uma
convivência feliz e tomara que pelo
menos 11 segundo tenha sido feliz como
eu fui ao longo desses minutos aqui com
você
muito obrigado e até a próxima se deus
quiser